[Applause]
happy
wednesday everyone or as the cuomo's
call it hump day
too easy i don't care so how is cnn
covering the chris cuomo scandal now he
was once their big star but now how do
they feel
honestly i never liked that dude to
begin with his hamptons parties this
summer not even that good yeah the
caviar was very subpar i can't believe
he made me stay in the guest house i
can't believe we had to play pool
volleyball in a non-heated pool
i had to wash
my
own
face
wow
wow i mean we're still going back next
year though right oh yeah definitely
cool
all right
i see done on tuesday anderson cooper
did address the suspension but look who
was with him on set as he did it
jeff tube and john dean appreciated some
news now about this network involves
chris cuomo the host of prime time
that's awkward
having tubin there as you discuss chris
it's a weird message you're sending that
at cnn you can't defend a prick but it's
all right to throttle one
in public
thank you emily
it also shows you how shallow the talent
pool is at cnn but i guess anthony
weiner was busy
[Laughter]
weiner meanwhile on his radio show chris
cuomo figured out who to blame
you can fight against the other party
and you can fight against the media but
only
if you have your party
he had the republicans hating him the
media never really liked them
so wait
the media never liked his brother
are you are you sure about that
how would you contrast cuomo and
president trump's handling of the crisis
truth versus mendacity my governor
governor cuomo i think is is one of the
heroes on the front lines even lifelong
republicans tell me they look at cuomo
and they're like god there's a leader
you see a spectacular political leader
emerging from this and andrew cuomo carl
what was the most important message you
heard from governor cuomo
real leadership
yeah i guess the media never liked him
and what better way to show their
dislike for someone than by awarding
them an emmy
following that logic i better start
building a trophy case tonight because i
hate my guts but as chris is being
dragged we're missing the big picture
and i don't mean a photo of brian
stelter's ass astrology sign
chris is in trouble for supporting his
brother so he's a terrible journalist
but a hell of a brother but what's the
media's excuse for doing the same thing
hate him or not chris did what any
family member would do and broke
whatever journalistic laws cnn still
observes in the process fire him i guess
but if cnn fired everyone for violating
basic journalism their newsroom would be
emptier than your medicine cabinet after
cat visits you
anyway
if anything were to happen to a sibling
or a child in your family a jerk or not
you'd probably do everything possible to
help them out except maybe jesse waters
family
kidnappers could mail them one of
jesse's fingers and they'd be like he's
got nine more
but if i ever get busted for something
and my sisters don't help me bury the
bodies they are out of the will
their loss is cars for kids gain
seriously what's the point of having
relatives if they're gonna rat you out
about the body under all that venison
you have in the freezer
that's why joe let hunter run all those
bribery schemes that and the ten percent
so i get chris but the media they don't
have that excuse they anointed his
brother the next president because they
liked his press conferences they're so
easy to fool that jesse smilet wishes
they were his jury
the media loved the governor
and they weren't related except by
ideology now the same people who say now
that he should be fired were right there
fawning over his brother as nursing home
patients bodies were stacking up like
sandbags along a swollen riverbank they
cared more about andy's sex life than
investigating the nursing home calamity
that was right in front of them and it
took sexual harassment to peak their
curiosity i get it sexual harassment is
bad if anyone's butt is getting slapped
it's my own and i pay consenting adults
dearly for that service
but it is interesting how the media
prioritizes and how they happily
disowned the very people they had
protected for so long when it suits them
but for a while they were on team cuomo
apparently top aides had been working
the press to convince them to support
the governor and they did in one case
cuomo aids reached out to schmooze a
writer for the atlantic who then quickly
wrote a piece entitled of course andrew
cuomo isn't going to resign well that
aged as well as macaulay culkin
yeah
it's a little like you i just want to
say that's insulting to me
liz smith an adviser to andrew cuomo
revealed that she texted with msnbc
anchor katie tour during the scandal and
claimed that the host repeated her spin
on air
msnbc the same place that still employs
a racist homophobe whose name rhymes
with joy reid
but i guess if everyone goes after chris
the creep doing the louis farrakhan
impression every night sneaks under the
radar and then there's cnn itself
they've unloaded fake news like it was
free government cheese james clapper
gets caught lying to congress about
intelligence then cnn hires him to
analyze intelligence
their russian collusion lie undermined
every institution for years their
attacks on police led to the funding of
cops contributing to violence that
destroyed cities they covered florida
when their coveted numbers spike now
that they're the lowest in america
they're quieter than matt lauer's work
phone
they targeted trumpers while coddling
rioters no wonder their ratings suck
their numbers get any lower they'll have
trouble paying nick sandman
and now they cover chris as though they
were on top of this all along
it was known that chris cuomo was
talking to his brother giving political
advice but in the newly released
documents you can see that chris cuomo
is essentially working as an unpaid
advisor an aide as if he is a staffer of
the governors giving political advice
giving commentary also working his own
sources to try to find out more about
what might be revealed about his brother
nice work pop and fresh
he reports those facts as if they
weren't pretending that the problem
didn't exist for months they hid this
story until they could hide it no longer
and yeah chris cuomo is a problem but
he's not the whole problem you know part
of the tumor has been removed but some
of it is still there and it's still
growing even as it expels one of its own
that's because the corporate press will
do what's good for the corporate press
and one and when one of their own goes
down they're just happy that it's not
them
let's welcome tonight's guests he's so
anti-woke sleep watch 24-7 author and
philosopher peter pagozian
later this former cheerleader will turn
this panel into a human pyramid
outnumbered co-host emily cabano
he's been behind more enemy lines than
jane fonda former cia operative and host
of black files declassified on discovery
side channel by baker
and she's like a raccoon big eyes active
at night and eats out of my trash can
[ __ ] this contributor cat tip
all right i've heard from everybody
about this except for you peter this is
the first time we've actually met first
time yes i'm a big fan of yours and i
hope you're a big fan of mine don't have
to say it but we understand
does cnn have any credibility left at
this point
uh it depends it depends what you think
if if the cuomo should be held to any
kind of journalistic integrity or
journalistic standards given that it's
not really a journalistic outlet it's a
propaganda machine so it is a little bit
unfair to hold him to a different but it
is though it is unfair to hold him to a
journalistic standard when the whole
point is to propagandize right but the
other thing is i do think we need to
give credit for the for the fact that he
was suspended yeah and i think it's
really important in these conversations
to
to when someone's across an aisle an
ideological divide you say if they do
the right thing you say they did the
right thing right and i think in this
case they did the right thing and he is
entitled to due process and if he's done
something illegal then then he should be
given his day in court all right so the
producers we're going to need to edit
that part out
the part where peter says they did the
right thing we're just gonna put in some
kind of
i know put in some kind of animal video
i think we have an animal video that we
could just drop right in there
make sure that never happens
oh you're supposed to talk to these
guests beforehand
emily how you doing
everything okay
oh that's great i'm so happy for you and
congratulations
i don't know
this felt like saying congratulations
what do you think is this going is he
cuz you're a lawyer i think well
so i claim as you say uh look to me this
is a ray rice situation cnn comes out
when they suspend him indefinitely with
the statement that says we now
understand the extent of his involvement
per these documents with his brother
really because meanwhile back in may
chris cuomo said on air he admitted that
he broke the network's rules in advising
his brother in public relations this
network had i would say a pretty extreme
transparency when in an op-ed the
executive producer talked about how she
was groped by him the same action that
his brother is being prosecuted for
under his own laws here in new york
state forcible touching he admitted so
in an email to her and yet the network
looked the other way so that kind of
culpability combined with his brother
that us as new york residents we've
already paid 9.5 million dollars for his
legal fees chris cuomo to me is just the
another fly in the ointment but to your
point i mean i think that's generous of
you to want to extend to him due process
i think at this point we should just
vigilante justice
[Applause]
get him off the street
wow
i like this kind of emily company yeah
who knew
yeah this scares me mike
yeah you're looking great by the way
thank you very much as are you yeah well
thank you what are you doing later yeah
it's been a while you know mike well i
swear it off but i haven't had butt
slapping but uh i you know it's it's uh
also by the way emily i played drums in
the 80s cover band called forcibly
touching
i i think peter raises a really easy
point not that stupid one about
but the other one where we're conflating
the idea that journalism automatically
equals objectivity people have kind of
forgotten that a lot of what they hear
is is legitimately just opinion
pieces right and it's and but when
you're talking about journalism
objectivity i don't think the 14 or 15
uh viewers that watched chris cuomo show
actually care about
you know journalistic integrity that's
not that doesn't play into sort of the
hard liberal mindset right that's not
what they're watching for they're
watching for red meat right yeah i mean
everybody goes to their particular
network to have their assumptions met
and i will even say that sometimes it
happens here
not with this show well not here ever no
no never it doesn't never happen but
but
peter's point too also it's kind of
interesting that cnn doesn't even bother
to label what is commentary or what is
fact we do that like we know tucker is
commentary we know that bill hammer is
news we know that but they don't even
bother with it well that's where that's
where the line's been blurred people get
confused and i mean like look
i do think the end result of all this is
i think cuomo is coming back i mean
people are comparing it to the jeffrey
toobin case uh per
i think it's actually different strokes
for different
[Laughter]
that all the folks
all day long i don't get it thank you i
don't get it
seriously
yeah he furiously masturbated exactly
you're excited right right yeah yeah
yeah yeah got it yeah something to say
i'm a little slow hey
um
yeah we're talking about the one
it's gonna be interesting cat like if he
doesn't come back that means both
brothers are out of work they should
open up an italian restaurant where they
can serve fettuccino fettuccine alfredo
[Music]
i've been saving that up since my friend
texted it to me
i gotta tell you that's almost as good
as my jokes
[Laughter]
um
i don't know what to ask you
that's okay answer the question that you
would like me to i mean i don't look uh
there's been a lot about
so
he just he like what about cuomo's
excuse family okay he like lied to the
attorney general didn't he ever talk
about the journalism stuff but he said
to the attorney general i wasn't doing
oppo research
then what is i've got a lead on the
wedding girl
what is that if not oppo research uh i
just think that he's had so many
scandals this i forgot about the
forcible touching and that shouldn't be
something that i forgot about because
that is a bad thing to do yes and it's a
bad thing to forget about yeah i'm i'm
the problem
you are the problem he comes back it's
like herpes i mean i really hope he does
we're just rewarding these guys
seriously can you imagine their
christmas dinner this year both of them
underwent they've been hanging out every
night yeah yeah there's not enough
ointment to take care of this problem no
tell me about it
anyway